this is the story of a dragon with
poison in his heart and it's a story of
the race that discovered him worshipped
his magnificence but ultimately perished
by his side
dragons have always been intriguing to
humanity with many believing they hold
the secrets to life itself one who
believed this was vendrick king of
drangleic and his brother aldea together
they experimented on dragons in the
hopes that they could learn more about
their existence eventually they were
successful recreating an ancient dragon
with the ability to peer into the past
to view the stories of all so that they
might learn from them this is one such
story in the ancient dragons eerie
before the chamber with the Dragon's egg
is a mural that depicts an ancient
civilization who existed long ago deep
below the deepest depths legend has it
that deep below the earth behind a door
locked from the inside is a magnificent
city built for a great slumbering dragon
in a bygone age the king in the depths
built his city around this beast this
subterranean world centered around the
great sanctum that housed the dragon in
its depths and was aptly named silver
the sanctum city this was a religious
City where sorceries were considered
taboo but miracles flourished as the
people there were grounded in their
faith the people prayed and worshiped
and the priestesses sang to soothe the
dragon in its slumber
one wonders whether a single phrase of
their song ever reached the dragon's
ears but to people of faith such
questions matter not as is common the
king had a dear Queen and the Queen sang
to the dragon also at this point in our
story you should know that the dragon
has a tragic secret deep within him sin
harbors a dreadful store of poison and
there will come a time where he cannot
bear it any longer looking back it's
impossible to know whether the people
knew over the poison or even if the
dragon himself knew perhaps the people
of the city prayed sang and soothed out
of fear fear that the waking of the
dragon would lead to their demise if so
this could only serve to strengthen
their faith for fear is the heart of
reverence and the people revered their
magnificent sleeping beasts the center
of their faith
it should come as no surprise to you
that men would come to cover the dragon
to the Drake blood Knights fresh dragon
blood was sacra scent they believed that
by obtaining it they could come to a
true understanding of life allowing them
to transcend their own pointless
existence in a world where strength of
purpose keeps one from hollowing a
belief like this isn't so strange led by
Sir York and his famous spear the Drake
blood Knights lay siege to Silva the
king of Silva called his sanctum Knights
to Arms many of whom renounced their own
flesh to eternally guard the sanctum
from the assault of Sir York and his
Drake blood Knights they were sentenced
to eternal stewardship yet soon the day
would come where the sanctum received
nary a visitor during the conflict the
dragon slept lulled by the Queen song
you have to wonder who sent sir York and
his Drake blood Knights so look now with
the crest upon the ring of suyog and see
the truth of things this is the crest of
drangleic so you're leader of the Drake
blood knights and possibly a vendrick's
Kingdom cuts down the soldiers of the
sanctum and kills the King in the depths
he then faces the slumbering dragon with
visions of dragon blood and omniscience
so your guesses the dragon with a flash
of his steel piercing sin through the
chest and as you can imagine it wasn't
what he was expecting sin immediately
awakens and from his wound spews forth
the deadly poison that had long been
brewing within him it blankets the
entire city in a miasma cloud restoring
the Dragons purity but toppling the city
so your gand his drake blood knights
disappeared into the sanctum and nothing
more was heard of the race that
discovered a dragon and worshipped its
magnificence
until now there have been many kings and
kingdoms hierarchies that rose and fell
leaving ruined kingdoms behind we visit
the memories of vendrick king of his own
unraveled kingdom I am no King I am more
fit to be a jester I was unaware of my
own blindness we have feeble vessels
with feebler souls we would cast aside
the prop of life only to face greater
hardship are you another such fool or
something no seeker of fire conqueror of
dark do you intend to link the fire then
you must first take the throne prove
your Worth find the ancient crowns seek
adversity and they will be yours and
your wishes grant it somewhere within
the sanctum is the crown of the sunken
King the crown of a king who came before
vendrick the crown of a king who was
killed by so you're gone the day that
the dragon awoke we explore the ruined
sanctum and we uncover the truths that
it holds the soldiers in the sanctum are
now undead coated with the corrosive
poison of the dragon but still carrying
out their orders to defend the sanctum
from outsiders throughout the sanctum we
find open chests which were a tribute to
the grave robbers and thieves who have
flocked to this place sin the sleeping
dragon now roams his domain sleeping
lightly where he pleases
even clears a bridge for us at one point
killing the two soldiers that block our
path dragons in all the law have always
kept to themselves they either think
themselves above man or do not care for
his conflicts you have to wonder about
sin did he Harbor malicious intent
he had poisoned in his heart but when he
was pierced by York's spear the poison
gushed out and restored his purity this
implies he was pure before which
suggests that the poison was placed
within him
but by whom we find an answer in the
sanctum right before sin
elana the squalid queen once again sings
to sin the slumbering dragon after the
kingdom is ruined by sins awakening she
remains alone I believe Alana sang the
song of poison into the dragon's heart
and was at least partly responsible for
the fall of the sunken King just like
her sister nashandra was responsible for
the fault of drangleic nothing
explicitly confirms Alana's intentions
except the pattern that repeats itself
we are discovering that all great Kings
have Queens that lay in wait waiting for
the right moment to strike
and it's easy to believe that the queen
of the sanctum City was partly
responsible for its for Alana defends
her sunken Kingdom with a mixture of
fire dark and most notably poison and
filth her essence is that of Filth and
neglect
she even summons a depraved replica of
the Kings hand fell stud completing the
image of a queen devoted to making a
mire of the world after we conquer Alana
we learn who she wants from her soul
seeker fire I see you've subdued another
foul creature one of the father of the
abyss spawn that confounded quintessence
of humanity the abyss once had foam but
then dissipated and yet traces of its
existence endured each fragment
thirsting for power spread dark with no
relent My dear Chandra was one such
fragment a feeble tiny thing but
thirsted for power more than any other
driven by insatiable lust for a worthy
vessel all Queens thus far are the
children of the sentient abyss that
existed long ago they are the pieces
that regained form in ways that hint at
humanity's true nature they seek to be
whole once again
alanna the queen of the sanctum King is
a child of wrath she's gathering Souls
and power from the slumbering dragon in
anticipation of the coming day of
vengeance her sister nashandra the queen
of drangleic is a child of what the
Kings dear Chandra seeks the throne and
the power to reshape the world that
comes with it for this she needs a
vessel nashandra guards the throne Elana
guards a crown I'm sure a third sister
lies in the remains of the old iron
King's Kingdom and we've yet to see her
it appears that the sisters are keeping
the crowns and the throne warm waiting
for some day of reckoning where they
avenged their father every king of light
has had a fragment of matter son doing
their efforts from the start like
vendrick says the brighter the flame the
deeper their shadow since death was a
result of our desire for the crown of
the sunken King for it is now our job to
gather the Crown's and Link the fire we
aim to be a lord of light that the
previous Kings weren't and we will
succeed in this but what if we have a
queen of our own
bearer of the curse I will always be at
your side until hope has fully withered